the word sustainability which 25 years
ago was really not in use at all
suddenly is now used everywhere and it
means a million different things to me
it's really about the well-being of
everyone else it's about changing
mindsets the ability for Humanity to
thrive on the planet using your feet
more than using a car it's about
knowledge it's about processes it's
about partnership building and it's
about
Vision this is a game that we need to be
in the campus is really the city because
we don't survive we don't sustain unless
the city that we're in sustains as
well we have per square foot one of the
most energy intensive campuses in the
world we're at the beginning of
grappling with this issue we thought
about you know what would it take to get
MIT to be Net Zero waste uh on campus
how do we measure and reduce the amount
of material handling that we
do
you need all the stakeholders together
to talk about it from all the different
perspectives so I'm really looking
forward to getting an opportunity to
learn those perspectives and maybe step
out of my comfort zone a little bit it's
an opportune time to really think about
what the campus should look like in 2025
in 2030 not only from the physical and
design standpoint from the operations
from the research Mission but also from
the sustainability what do we experiment
with and what do we prove can be done we
know we have to do things differently we
have to be more efficient with our
resources our macro view was reduce
fossil fuel dependency our micro view
was maximize passive strategies the
challenges we face now with climate
change are existential challenges for
Humanity over the long term but in the
near-term profound economic and
humanitarian challenges we talked about
all the data that everyone is generating
and that it's really compelling when you
can create information Graphics that
help people understand that data and
actually make decisions turn things off
turn things down strategies all this
requires assurance and Trust in the
research community that their research
won't be impacted negatively we've had
great representation here today of a
real diversity of Staff we've had
faculty here we've had students here I
see the issue of climate change in
general as a social justice issue
technology is no longer the bottleneck
we have so many of the Technologies we
need to begin taking climate action
and what we really lack is the societal
and especially political will to really
take meaningful action what would you do
to solve this problem rather than being
prescriptive about the the solutions
just saying this is what we're trying to
do and then what MIT does best is
innovate the question really becomes for
MIT does it want to be a leader in
sustainability this whole effort is
about capacity building building the
capacity of an institution to deal with
truly complex issues MIT has a huge
opportunity for its scientists to play a
larger role in making relevant climate
science to decision-making context and
working with the city of Boston
Cambridge the broader New England region
and globally to help people make
decisions based on what we know is going
to happen in terms of disruption today
went a long way toward all of us having
a common understanding what
sustainability means to MIT as we're
reflecting on today as a opportunity to
connect on sustainability I think that
we've got some some real successes there
and I think we also have room to
grow